PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
Welcome to the biochemistry
help sessions.
This is the covalent bonds,
chirality, electronegativity,
and hydrogen bonds module.
In this help session, I'll be
going over the first practice
problem in this module.
If you have not had a chance
to look over this problem
yourself, please go back, look
over the problem, try it, and
then come back and we'll
go through it together.
Now that you've had a chance to
look at the problem, let's
get started.
First of all, what
is this molecule?
To me, this molecule looks
like it's a sugar.
It's a polysaccharide, to be
exact, and it's actually a
chain of glucose molecules.
So in this problem, the first
part of the problem asks us to
name each circled bond
in this molecule.
So the first circled bond is
right here, and this is a
carbon to carbon bond.
Now, the first thing that we can
notice about this bond is
that it's a carbon to carbon
bond, and we know that carbon
only forms covalent bonds
in biological systems.
So the first thing we can say
is that this bond is a
covalent bond.
Second, we need to decide
if this bond is
polar or non polar.
And the way we decide that
is we look at the
electronegativity of
the atoms involved.
In this bond we have
two carbons.
And so since they're the same
atoms, we know that they have
the same electronegativity.
And bonds between two atoms of
the same electronegativity are
non polar bonds.
So we know that this carbon
to carbon bond is
covalent and non polar.
Now we'll look at the
second bond circled.
This bond is a carbon
to oxygen bond.
It is similar to the first
bond in that it involves
carbon, so we can say that
it is a covalent bond.
What's different about this
bond, however, is that it is a
carbon bound to an oxygen.
And when you look at the
electronegativities of carbon
and oxygen, you find that
oxygen is much more
electronegative than carbon.
So in a carbon to oxygen bond,
you actually have oxygen is
greedy, and it's going to take
the electrons closer to itself
and not share them equally
with the carbon.
So in this kind of bond,
oxygen will be slightly
negative and carbon will be
slightly positive, because the
electrons are attracted
closer to the oxygen.
In a bond where you have a
slightly negative side and a
slightly positive side, we
call this a polar bond.
So we can say that a carbon to
oxygen bond is a polar bond.
So in this first part, we
learned that the difference
between a covalent and
a non polar and a
covalent polar bond.
The second part of the problem,
part B, asks if this
sugar molecule is soluble
in water.
So first you need to know
whether this molecule is polar
or non polar.
And since we know that it has
carbon to oxygen bonds, we
know that it has polar bonds,
so it is a polar molecule.
And what do we know
about water?
We know water is an oxygen
bound to two hydrogens.
And since it has this very
electronegative oxygen, we
know that it is also
a polar molecule.
And an easy rule of thumb is
that like dissolves like.
So since these are both polar
molecules, sugar dissolves
very easily in water.
If you had a fat, on the other
hand, which is a non polar
molecule, it would not
dissolve in water.
That's why when you put
oil and water, you
don't see it dissolve.
So now that we understand why
sugar dissolves very easily in
water, we'll move into the third
part of the problem,
where they ask what types of
bonds can form between these
long polymers.
So looking at these polymers,
the first thing that we can
notice is that there are these
oxygens and hydrogens on each
of the polymers.
And looking at these, we can see
how you can have hydrogen
bonding, which we learned about
in class, between the
oxygen of one sugar molecule
to the hydrogen of another
sugar molecule, thus forming
hydrogen bonding networks
between the sugar molecules.
And in this way, they can
interact with each other.
So in this help session we have
covered the difference
between a covalent non
polar bond and a
covalent polar bond.
We have covered why water can
dissolve sugar very easily,
and what kind of bonds
can form between
these two sugar molecules.
Thank you.